>> Jesse: WELCOME BACK.
WELL, THE MIDTERMS USE TO BE
LIKE BORING, DIDN'T THEY?
>> YOU KNOW, THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS USED TO BE LIKE
BORING, DIDN'T THEY?
DO YOU EVEN REMEMBER WHAT THEY
WERE?
YOU SAY MIDTERMS, PEOPLE WOULD
SAY WHAT IS THAT?
IT IS THE HOTTEST THING.
>> Greg: THE MIDTERMS ARE
REALLY MORE LIKE SPRING BREAK
FOR UNDER TOLD DEMING TO MIKE
OLDER CHILDREN.
THEY SEE NOTHING BUT EVIL IN
TRUMPET.
THANKS DEMS GONE WILD.
NOW THEY ARE EVEN STRIPPING.
>> SO TO LIKE YOUR LIFE DEPENDS
ON IT.
I WILL BE AT THE HEADQUARTER
CAMPAIGNS, WE WILL BE AT -- I
WILL BE AT UC IRVINE.
>> Greg: THAT IS AN ACTUAL
ADULT.
SO EXACTLY TWO YEARS AGO, THESE
KIDS GOT THEIR BLIND RAGE ON AND
NEVER TOOK IT OFF.
THERE WAS NO PLEASING THEM,
ESPECIALLY IF THEY ARE WELL OFF
ENOUGH NOT TO BE AFFECTED BY THE
JOB MARKET.
THEY DON'T NEED TRUMP THE WAY
THAT THE REST OF AMERICA DOES,
AND TRUMP DOES MAKE A GREAT
TARGET.
HE IS A LAW & ORDER GUY.
IT IS ONE WORD.
IT BOUNDARIES.
BOUNDARIES EXIST TO BRING
FORWARD GOAL.
WYOMING IS JUST ANOTHER CHUNK OF
THE PLANET.
ADD OFFENSES AND YOU GET ORDER
AND LOGIC.
YOU NEED THEM FOR A COUNTRY'S
IDENTITY.
AND YOU NEED THEM AS LAW.
IT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO LEAD FREE
LIVES WITHOUT HARM.
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
ANY LAW & ORDER STANCE BECOMES
HEARTLESS BECAUSE THE LEFT
SEPARATES THE PROCESS, WHICH IS
ENFORCING LAWS, FROM THE
RESULTS, WHICH IS CREATING
ORDER.
SO MILITARY, COPS, I.C.E.
THEY ARE JUST BIG MEANIES.
IT IS CHILDISH TO BELIEVE THAT
THEY DON'T LEAD TO BETTER LIVES.
IT IS ADULTS VERSUS THOSE WITH A
TEENAGE VIEW OF THE WORLD.
AND EVEN THOUGH THE KIDS KNOW
THAT WITHOUT GROWN-UPS, THEY
WOULD BE DEAD.
WHO CARES?
BECAUSE THE ADULTS WILL ALWAYS
BE AROUND, HURTING FEELINGS,
MAKING LIFE POSSIBLE.
KIDS JUST HAVE A HARD TIME
FORGIVING GROWN-UPS WERE MAKING
LIFE IMPOSSIBLE.
A PERFECT EXAMPLE, DANA, BILL
de BLASIO, THE MAYOR OF
NEW YORK, I CALL HIM STUPIDZILL
STUPIDZILLA.
IF THERE WASN'T A SECURITY BED
ALREADY MADE FOR HIM BY GIULIANI
AND BLOOMBERG, NEW YORK WOULD BE
IN CHAOS.
MAINLY BECAUSE OF HIS IDEOLOGY,
IT FORBIDS BEING PRO-COP AND PRO
LINE ORDER.
HE INHERITS THIS SO THAT HE CAN
BE EVEN MORE AGGRESSIVE.
>> Dana: NOW HE IS IN HIS
SECOND TERM, SO YOU CAN
ABSOLUTELY SEE THAT.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
SIT DOWN AND ACTUALLY THINK WHAT
ARE THEY FOR ON IMMIGRATION?
ASIDE FROM BUILDING A WALL,
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S POLICIES ARE
VERY MUCH LIKE BARACK OBAMA'S.
THEY ARE NOT ALL THAT DIFFERENT.
THE DEPORTATION, THE USE OF
I.C.E.
THE FAMILY SEPARATION, WE HAVE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THAT.
OBVIOUSLY -- COURSE CORRECTION
ON THAT ONE.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR.
THEY WILL NOT WIN IN RACES WHERE
REPUBLICANS HAVE WON IF THEY
DON'T FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO SAY ON IT.
>> Greg: WHAT SHOULD THEY DO,
LAURA?
>> Laura: I JUST HAVE TO SAY
THAT RIGHT NOW GETTING INTO HOW
THE MEDIA HAS BEEN SO IN THE BAG
FOR THE DEMOCRATS, RIGHT NOW,
THERE IS A HEADLINE THAT SAYS
"WHATEVER THE RESULTS TONIGHT,
BETO O'ROURKE SAID TO EMERGE
VICTORIOUS."
OF COURSE, IF YOU LOSE, YOU WIN.
IF YOU WIN, YOU WIN.
I THINK THE WAY THAT WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THIS, PEOPLE DO YOU LIKE
DIVIDED GOVERNMENT.
IT IS A LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH
HERE.
WE WILL TRY IT.
IF THINGS DON'T GO WELL THEN,
MAYBE THEY WILL THROW THAT PARTY
OUT.
PEOPLE IN THE MOOD TO KIND OF
GIVE REPORT CARDS.
I'M TELLING YOU, JESSE AND GREG,
ON THE SUBSTANCE, YOU CANNOT
ARGUE WITH TRUMP POLICY.
THEY ARE WINNING ACROSS THE
BOARD.
JUAN, THAT HAS BEEN TRENDING
UPWARD.
BETTER THAN IT WAS IN 2010.
THAT IS INTERESTING.
>> Juan: MAYBE THAT'S WHY HIS
APPROVAL RATING IS SO LOW,
LAURA.
>> Laura: IT'S HIS
PERSONALITY.
>> Laura: IT'S NOT 51.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> Juan: TO YOUR POINT, I JUST
WANT TO SAY AS SOMEONE SITTING
HERE, I WANT TO STAND UP FOR THE
YOUNG PEOPLE.
>> Greg: THE ONLY ONE VOTING
FOR YOU --
>> Juan: WHAT WE KNOW IS A
STATE LIKE GEORGIA, FOUR TIMES
THE RATE OF TURN OUT IN 14.
IN TEXAS AND NEVADA, FIVE TIMES,
WHAT DO YOU OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
MORE ENGAGED.
THIS GOES TO THE TOP OF YOUR
MONOLOGUE.
TRUMP HAS MADE MIDTERMS MORE
RELEVANT, MORE INTERESTING, MORE
ESSENTIAL FOR AMERICANS.
AND I THINK WE ENGAGE PEOPLE IN
THE POLITICAL PROCESS WHO
PREVIOUSLY THOUGHT MIDTERMS, NO.
AND FROM A DEMOCRATIC
PERSPECTIVE, THEY THOUGHT
HILLARY CLINTON IS GOING TO WIN,
SO WHY BOTHER?
>> Jesse: YET, TRUMP MAKES
EVERYTHING HOT RIGHT NOW.
THE ECONOMY, TWITTER, TRADE.
LEAKERS AND LIBERALS.
ALSO SOME NEGATIVE THINGS.
WE NOW KNOW THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IT BUT IF YOU PUT TRUMP'S NAME
IN FRONT OF EVERYTHING, IT JUST
MAKES IT GOOD.
A FOUR INSTANCE, I ONLY EAT
TRUMP AT STAKE.